Tory and I have known each other since
2008 we never did this before I'm going
to ask you Tory to just start out
filling in
because Tory's background is very
unusual for what she turned out to do
and there are some kind of I think
unlikely elements in your past including
the fact that you grew up not caring at
all about fashion and that's true I we
were laughing this morning but I'm from
Valley Forge Pennsylvania and I grew up
on a farm I often say in the middle of
nowhere because that was intentional and
my parents part they wanted to move out
of the main line to really have a
childhood to focused on sports and
family and when I say family we had
family night dinner every night and that
was a must
until my brothers went to boarding
school I grew up with three brothers and
it was spending all day outside everyday
playing tennis riding horses not really
thinking about fashion that said having
very fashionable parents and I often
said that my father should have been a
designer because he designed all of his
clothing and had impeccable taste and my
mother as well and I remember as a child
just watching them in all going out at
night and just thinking wow is so not me
I was a tomboy I had short hair and I
was interested in just competing with my
brothers I'm gonna do something that's
kind of inelegant here we are sitting on
the wrong side we could either change
change seats
let's change I'm happy let's change
these because we want to make sure that
the video and the audio quality is is
good and better now right now we can now
we can actually talk to each other
um so Tori you went to Penn you were an
art history major I found in my three
decades of reporting about very sick
vessel people that most of them had no
idea in college what they wanted to do
with their careers and I have a theory
about that that's what keeps you
flexible and open to possibilities but
what were you thinking in your senior in
your senior year at Penn about what you
wanted to do with your life it's funny
you say that I think when I meet
students now that's very different
everyone seems to know exactly where
they're going but I really didn't know I
loved art art and I loved my major of
art history and thought I had worked at
Christie's in the summer and and thought
maybe that route I had gone on a program
called semester at sea so I knew that I
loved to travel in different cultures
and but there was a designer that my
mother wore and I cold called him and
his name is Zoran he looked like rest
butan and he I said can I have a job you
know I can do anything and everything
and he said you can have a job you have
to start a week after graduation and
that wasn't exactly in my plan but
that's what I did and it was this crazy
induction into fashion he was a
minimalist he never used buttons zippers
anything on his clothing he dressed
beautiful women Lauren Hutton Jackie O
the vodka started at 10:00 in the
morning he had no desks it was he his
partner and me and my job was to get
coffee and then to lie to people and
tell them that he wasn't in the office
when he was there when they came to shop
so it was anything and everything he
didn't particularly like women he always
wanted to cut my hair he never wanted me
to dress up and look feminine so it was
crazy I grew up on a farm and all this
and I'm in New York and fashion in a big
way how long did you stay well I stay
there I was there a year and while I was
there I met a woman named candy pres
price so I'm sure many you know she
started style calm and she was this
force and amazing and so she knew my
sister-in-law and she offered me a job
to go to Harper's Bazaar so I went there
and I was an assistant sittings
assistant so I went on all the shoots
and worked with Scavullo and Patrick to
marché and when
as an assistant and just saw incredible
styling so I thought that that was
amazing to see as well and then from
there went to Ralph Lauren in PR I
started and then I think Ralph is really
where I learned most about what I knew
about branding and and and just what is
he such a great training ground I wrote
I was the copywriter also so anything
written that came out of Ralph Lauren I
wrote whether it's a press release or an
ad but just fantasy I thought just the
world of Ralph and escapism and giving
people the ability to dream and to see
hit the world up I used to call the one
of the people that work there polo
Christians because they were complete
you had to work there and where Ralph
head-to-toe and so but in a good way
everyone loved it and I would say I met
some of my closest girlfriends there and
everyone that I know in fashion at some
one point or another has worked at Ralph
Lauren and it's a great training ground
so and you met Vera Wang so while I was
there Vera Wang was working there and
she decided to go off on her own and
start a bridal company and we were
friends and several years later she
called me and said would you run
advertising and PR for me because I want
to take me being a bridal designer to
take to the next level and become
ready-to-wear designer so to me that was
very interesting is very entrepreneurial
and it was starting from scratch and and
really how to how to brand her and
position her and be her publicist also
and I don't know if anyone knows Vera
but she had no holds bar she has no
editing skills and to deal with
journalists and Vera it was always a
challenge so you had one more step in
your corporate career path before you
went on your own and that was at LVMH so
I had always been a big fan of Narciso
Rodriguez and he was working at louisv
which was a incredible leather brand
that they wanted to bring to the US so
they they asked me to work with Narciso
and and bring that to the US and then
they offered me to be president and I
was so excited
ready to take it and then found out I
was pregnant with my third boy and so I
realized that it just wasn't possible to
be a mom have three boys under the age
of four and a career like that and so it
was a very difficult decision but I
realized that my father wasn't well I
wanted to spend more time with him so I
moved down to Philadelphia and quit
completely and took time off to be a mom
about four years so Tori's twin boys are
now 15 and her younger son is 11 so you
take a few years off and you're not
really off because you're plotting well
knowing that said when I took the time
off knowing that I always wanted to work
and work with so much part of what I
loved philanthropy is something I loved
and I was trying to figure out how how
do you combine the two and that was what
I spent a lot of time in Philadelphia
thinking about I knew that there was a
company that my mother always wore
called Jack's and it was out of La the
designer was pretty Gernreich and it was
just great American sportswear and it
didn't seem to cost a fortune that
wasn't what it was I guess back then it
was fairly expensive but that was my
impression of it and so I called Sally
Hansen I cold called her she was a
serial entrepreneur she was 90 and I
said can I get the name Jax and she said
absolutely not I said okay so then I had
to regroup and start thinking of the
concept that I wanted to do not having
her name and there are many iterations
many names trying to get this idea of
accessible luxury started to take shape
it was something that I personally was
missing I I didn't want to spend
designer price points every time I went
shopping I wanted to find beautifully
made beautifully tailored clothing that
were not a designer and who was doing
that best at the time I didn't think it
was being done at the time and and and
also in a retail concept I thought it
was interesting this idea of starting a
store that would be completely a
lifestyle concept so you walked in
and you saw who we were from the
beginning whether it was the logo or the
Hang tags or the candle that was burning
and I also knew that I had a friend to
have a friend a great friend named Fiona
Couture and she helped Mickey Drexler
startle Navy so she introduced me to
someone in Hong Kong to set up an office
from day one and that was how we would
achieve the price points we needed to
achieve so as many long trips to China
and all over China many trips to Hong
Kong with image books I had worked years
on and taking it into factories and cold
calling people and saying listen you
know this is an idea if you take a
chance on me we'll be with you long term
and really we are with many of the same
factories we started off with so what
did you do differently than most startup
people in fashion what what did you do
that most of them did not do well number
one I had no experience so I had no
design experience I had never gone to
business school and what I was raised
with parents that taught me I could do
anything if I put my mind to it I grew
up with three brothers I didn't realize
there was a difference from a gender
standpoint about men could do things and
women couldn't I I guess I was putting
myself out there as I said I didn't want
to use my name all the names I wanted to
get you to use I couldn't get so I start
why didn't you want to use your name I
just I I did not want to put myself out
there in that way there was a lot of
negativity there was a lot of raised
eyebrows and when I started the company
my parents said thicken your skin this
is going to be if it takes all if it's
going to be hard at times and you're
going to have to listen or not listen to
the negativity and think of it as noise
and really just believe in what you're
going to do
and and don't read anything that's
negative and and and just believe in
yourself
so did you consider other names besides
Torre Berg Danny names Patti we tries to
get so many names they're all taken so
what did you consider me oh my gosh I
can't remember I mean there's so many
but what it turned out to be was Tori by
TRB and my maiden name was Robinson so
that was the that was what was on the
Hang tags in the beginning
two years later Kenny J Lane who's this
great sort of sports and costume jewelry
pulled me aside and he's a second father
to me and he said for God's sakes don't
call it Tori by TRB it's a terrible name
everyone calls the tory burch anyway I
change it and in the end he was right
and we and we did change it did it seem
so you're a very private person so did
it seem too intrusive or did it seem
egotistical well I certainly didn't want
it to be a vanity project and and I am
and was extremely private so it was very
hard to use her name number one we had
no idea that this company would be where
it is today we as he said it was meant
to be three stores and a five-year plan
and I worked for the first two years out
of our apartment
it was very bare-bones I I remember our
president came to interview she is
president Michael Kors at the time and
and they told her she was committing
career suicide by coming by coming to me
and she's still with me she's really
helped build this brand and was that
2041 4005 so she came a year after but I
still working out of my apartment we
were working out of the apartment until
we had 16 people I had three little boys
running around I'm very close to my
stepdaughters they're like my kids as
well so six kids bored swatches I had
appointments and it was mayhem
what about opening so Tory's first store
opened in downtown Elizabeth Street
downtown New York not a not Madison
Avenue a cool but you know kind of edgy
part of town in 2004 and
opened with in a store in like with 15
categories of merchandise which was kind
of gutsy at the time wasn't it yes in
retrospect very what what kind of advice
were you get I was basically told I was
crazy by so many people like what am i
doing this is insane and what was insane
what would I say you know that you start
and you work with a wholesaler and then
you build your brand and you start with
Footwear you start with ready-to-wear
you know you don't start with I mean we
did umbrellas we did swim we did
ready-to-wear and we launched Fashion
Week 2004 in February and we invited I
growing up in fashion it was amazing to
see the support of other editors
out-of-town press my stepdaughters and I
worked literally through the night we
opened this door without doors and I had
my brothers running out to Southampton
to get pillows everything was like was
crazy just group of people trying to get
one store ready on Elizabeth Street
which at the time there was really
nothing it was a restaurant a great
restaurant cafe Habana that was
basically was there and then we opened
and from 10:00 in the morning until 6:00
at night it was friends family
out-of-town press press and we virtually
sold through our inventory so why didn't
you want to go the single line wholesale
route to get off the ground why did you
want to open a store with a you know
with a with a with a broad line that
that obviously define the the tory burch
vision but a lot of people thought was
sort of excessive in its ambition why
did you want it was excessive but I
thought it was a way that we could be
off the radar it was a Street completely
out of the way and then we could sort of
learn our customer and see what worked
and see what didn't and for me it was
also a way of seeing what we could
source in different parts of the world
it wasn't just China it was we made some
things in New York we made some things
in Rhode Island and India so it was it
was really just sort of a
my idea a lab to see what could be done
and you plan three stores in the first
five years and how many stores did you
end up opening in thee in the first five
years Oh probably about 4045 so I mean
the first year of our business
I've thought my brothers are playing a
joke on me we got a call from Oprah and
I started saying oh sure hey Oprah it
wasn't Oprah going from her team and she
said you know they're doing a show on
the next big thing and and they picked
us for fashion and as it turned out it
was real they came then they filmed in
New York someone had given her a
Christmas present and she started to
wear it and the next day we had 8
million hits on our website which was
hard to define how much he helped the
success of our company but it's and what
year was that that was 2005 so Tori just
to update Garth's numbers Tori's
business today includes 83 stores 50 in
the United States 33 abroad revenues
over 800 million the online store is the
biggest of those of those stores you
were very early on the web invested in
that very early on and it has paid off
what has happened in the past year is
the biggest crisis in the life of the
tory burch company as tory burches
company which is that Tori's ex-husband
Chris Burch they were married for ten
year a decade and they have three boys
and three stepdaughters he was a co
investor when they started the company
you both put in a million dollars and
raised six million from friends and
family to start Tory Burch were equal
shareholders in the company and Tori's
ex-husband started
doing things that were competitive with
Tory even though he was still on the
board and one of the things he did was
he opened see wonder stores and these
see wonder stores became a big legal
battle but in the mind of Tory and her
management were very similar and
competitive to the tory burch stores
both in design and in the merchandise
and it became a big legal battle and
they settled a couple of weeks ago and
the settlement involved Chris selling
about half of his 28 percent stake in
Tory Burch to to investors general
Atlantic private equity firm and BDT
partners which is a investment firm
owned by a guy named Byron trot who used
to work for Goldman Sachs and was Warren
Buffett's banker and BDT has stakes in
few companies that you may know like
Weber grill and caribou coffee and now
tory burch so sorry for that long-winded
explanation part of the agreement of the
legal settlement is the Tauri cannot
talk about this but I'm going to ask you
a question that I think you'll be able
anyway the question that I will ask is
that this is every entrepreneurs
nightmare to have a partnership gone
awry to have investor relationships that
go bad it happened to Facebook it
happened to Apple when Steve Jobs left
the company happened to Tory so what
advice can you give to entrepreneurs in
the audience or entrepreneurs to be who
have to think about who do I partnership
who do I partner with and how many how
many investors do I want to give in
bring into the company and how much do I
give away
ya know I mean I think that's a great
very good question one thing I see all
the time with entrepreneurs is that they
give too much of their company away way
too soon and that's something that I
think needs to be really thought about
and and who you bring in and and we are
so lucky to have met the partners that
we recently just brought in but I will
say it was not a just met situation we
really spent a lot of time getting to
know bill forward and bar and trot and
feel it not only will they add
tremendous value to our company but they
share our vision and and really it is
about having a common vision about where
you see the company going we're a very
patient brand despite this growth we've
had it's been very strategic and
thought-out and we always in every
decision we make think about how is it
going to affect the company 5 10 years
from now and it really is about I laugh
was a friend of mine lonardo Ferragamo
whose mother is Wanda Ferragamo she
still is coming into the office at 85
and I said you know I want to be your
mom I mean I don't ever not see working
so you don't want to pre yourself in a
position where you have to leave your
company and I have seen that I've seen
it with great friends and it's a very
sad thing so a lot of investors have
wanted to put money into this private
company Tory Burch which is now valued
at over 2.5 billion dollars and you
spent about a year deciding who you
wanted to bring in as an investor can
you tell us anything about that process
can you tell us what kind of questions
you ask to potential investors and what
what were the most important questions
that they asked you well they got to
know our business through through many
different venues through actually just
people they knew through consulting
companies but I think the most important
aspect of it all is instinct and just
seeing if there is a
energy and integrity and and both of the
people that you just mentioned have
extremely high integrity and that's the
most important thing to me and also you
see how they treat people and one of the
most important parts of our company is
the culture and that is something that
we want to protect in an enormous way we
don't want to bring someone in that will
in any way change the culture that we've
worked so hard to build so how do you so
I have a like as a journalist and as a
profiler of you know important people
important successful and usually very
wealthy people if I'm if I'm doing a big
story about them I really like to see
them either in a restaurant or in a car
cuz you see in a cab in a cab ideally a
cab you know where I'm going so how do
you how do you assess the kindness of
and the sort of basic goodness of
potential investors I say something to
my 15 year old boys and my 11 year old
everyday and they're really tired of
hearing it wait I say a gentleman is not
a part-time job you are who you are and
you're either a gentleman or you're not
and I do not understand people that
treat people differently regardless of
who they are and when we talk about
hiring people we say and Bridget our
president this is the first thing I said
to her and she said that's what sealed
the deal I said you know I've worked in
a lot of places that said they're all
great places and great experiences but I
don't want a fashion environment
I can't do it and I want a very
straightforward place to work I want a
place that expects incredible work but
also expects people to have an
incredible life because I feel that's
the best way to get the best work out of
people is when they're extremely happy
and it's more of an extended family and
really is what we have I think I see
many some of our team here and they can
speak for themselves I don't speak for
them but I'd really do believe that if
you create an environment where you want
to work you're going to get outstanding
work and I'm not a big micro manager I
hire incredible teams and I believe in
them and I'm not telling them I am
putting my trust in them and we share a
common vision it's a lot about
transparency it's a lot about talking
about who we are where we want to go how
we see the company so it's it's where we
talk about being an open company and
Tory now has about 2,000 employees and
you're planning to open 35 stores this
year give or take depending that's very
aggressive expansion what have you
decided not to do what's funny I mean I
think another thing about what we talk
about with the company is restraint and
and really we never regret saying no
whether it's different partnerships
whether it's a diffusion line whether
it's you know opening a store that's not
in the exact location we want to be
patient we want to wait and we never
regret not doing things I think that
licensing is something we take very
seriously we I'm not a huge fan of
licensing unless it's what we need to do
and and we have three potential we have
two great licensing partners one that's
we're about to sign but we've never
advertised before we'll have our first
advertising campaign never advertised
it's kind of amazing because you it is a
very well-known brand so your first ad
campaign is it will be R that day Lauder
and that will be in September with our
first fragrance so and that was a five
year conversation Evelyn was a mentor to
me I'm on the board of the Breast Cancer
Research Foundation and sloan-kettering
so I've spent a lot of time working with
Evelyn and I always such an admired her
greatly so we he died of cancer about
she died and
years ago maybe a year ago but you sign
we sign the deal three months before she
died so it was it was great it was a
five-year conversation and we we did get
it done
we also license I wear with luxottica
and soon-to-be watches soon-to-be
watches what their areas do you want to
get into not necessarily licensing I
mean extending your brand you're the
tory burch brand what other areas well I
think our foundation is such a big part
of our brand as you mentioned and so we
want to continue to grow that and grow
it in tandem with the company which is a
fine line because we want to do great
things for the foundation but it also
has to be great for the company let's
talk about the foundation because we
really haven't and I met Tory in 2008
over breakfast she told me one of the
reasons that I started my company is
because I have always wanted to build a
foundation which no one had ever no
entrepreneur had ever said that to me it
was very odd that she said that and here
it was 2008 she had started the company
in 2004 a why didn't you start the
foundation she had not launched the
foundation yet when we met why why did
you take five years to launch the
foundation and how did you decide who
what and who you wanted to support with
your foundation work well number one we
didn't have the funds to start the
foundation so we knew that in order to
start a foundation we needed to have a
successful or on the way to be a
successful company so that was part of
it women and children I knew would be
the focus I wasn't exactly sure and I
think when I first met you I was going
to Haiti to do some research on
microfinance organizations and as it
turned out it just after a lot of
working and thinking and talking to
people we decided that
the one we were startup we were
entrepreneurs and that's something that
maybe we could help women start
businesses women have a harder time
getting a microloan in the US and they
do in developing countries so we thought
let's start in the US and then go from
there and and as I was saying a little
while ago to some friends backstage it's
it's not just about women's empowerment
through microfinance and mentorship we
want to be socially responsible in all
issues we want our company to be a
platform in a careful way for instance
when the disaster happened in Japan we
want to react on that or not tell them
what we did one the social media was a
perfect example in social media is the
way that we have built our company but
one of our team members put a graphic up
and and someone tweeted to saying you
should use your graphic on a t-shirt
and we did and we turned it around maybe
in two weeks and we raised close to half
a million dollars for the Japanese Red
Cross and and to me that just showed me
that we we have an opportunity to create
change and and we can use the company in
a way that benefits the company and is
authentic so it's not a marketing tool
that's something we always want to be
careful of with hurricane sandy we were
doing a sample sale for the foundation
and I was at a board meeting for the
CFDA and I and I said we have the space
should we turn it into an industry event
and have it not go to our foundation
have it go to the mayor's fund and
literally within a week between vogue
the CFDA and our foundation and a
tremendous amount of effort we turned it
into a sort of mini seventh on sale and
and raised at a fair amount of money for
the marathon so we want to be able to do
things like that who has questions ah if
you could go to the microphones on both
sides here and ask your questions that
would be great
um first of all thank you so much for
coming here today
I saw you in Gossip Girl the third
season that's embarrassing what do you
think what do you think about the men's
line and I'm really tired of seeing
everyone wearing a Baz tie right now so
what do you think about men's fashion
I do feel a second part of that I'm
tired of seeing everyone wearing a mess
tied yeah that is great so I have three
brothers and three boys so I get a
tremendous amount of pressure on men's
and it's definitely at some point I
would love to do that more in maybe a
gift-giving ties swim trunks or
something dress shirts but one thing I
find is that we really have to keep our
focus and we could be pulled in so many
different directions so we want to
really build the businesses within our
business as as we go but men's is
definitely something we want to do so
have to wait for a while well my boy my
boy hi I must say my boys wear our logo
belts I don't know if that's a good
thing or not I can't decide but it's
really cute when they wear them thank
you very much what about though the I
think that the sportswear category is a
category that you've been interested in
and and you know you go into a Tory
Burch store and there are sort of little
home elements but the home category is
something that you may expand into you
know home Patti I love I just have been
looking at that business is such a tough
business and so that's probably not in
the near future Sport is something I'm a
little more interested in and that's
something that we're very all very
excited about we might we see that in
the next year I would say maybe in the
next couple years okay and we're talking
what are we talking like tennis we are I
mean is it potentially a competition
with like Lululemon I would never say
that
do not quote me on that I would look at
them as mentors no I'm just kidding no I
think they have an incredible business
but I think yoga running I love tennis
personally golf to a lesser extent do I
love but I have so many friends that
love golf I don't I don't play but just
sports in general I think in in a
lifestyle way would be interesting yes
hello oh um Torrey thank you so much for
coming I was wondering if you have any
ever seen any tension between working in
fashion and being taken seriously
specifically when you work with
investors and you know high-level male
executives have you ever encountered
this and if so how do you deal with it I
I have seen that a lot and it's very
frustrating for me and that's why part
of our foundation was so much about
supporting women entrepreneurs and just
the idea of getting more women in the
workforce more women on boards more
women CEOs I was a few months ago
introduced as a female CEO I started to
laugh I got up there and I said I've
never in my life heard a man introduced
as a male CEO and it was just so telling
and I just said you know pay inequity
things like that to mere unacceptable
and I think it's time that we you know
part of the problem is the family work
balance and it's very difficult and it's
hard for me as well it's it's hard to
raise a family and be a CEO and I think
it's doable but it's a challenge and
that's why in our company I want to try
to start by making it a little easier to
do that and it's not necessarily about
how much time you spend there but it's
the quality of work what is your best
advice to women who have the kind of
family situation I mean six kids um and
you're you know CEO startup I mean you
know almost a 10 year old startup at
this point but star still still the
startup mentality right feels like a
start-up still so how do you get it all
done
well it's a challenge and I think it's
about time management and prioritizing I
definitely don't sleep a lot which is
something I never have so I think that
works to my advantage I sleep I sleep
about four or five hours a night you get
up at 5:30 don't you I got up about 5:30
6:00 I want to my boys get up in 7:00 so
I get up maybe six and then work out I
sometimes I can't say it every day but I
can but no I
if I wasn't a great mother I wouldn't be
a great CEO so my children
why do you say that because I wouldn't
be able to do it my children are the
most important thing in my life and they
know that and they feel that and I take
them to school every morning I'm home by
6:30 when I can i I am basically a
single mom their father travels a lot so
I really have to be there to help with
homework that it's hard for me to do
it's learning chemistry in American
history again right now so but I love I
love being a mom so for me it's and I
love being a CEO it's just a challenge
and there's no getting around that what
is the best business building advice
that you ever got and what is the best
life advice that you ever got well
business building is hiring people that
are smarter and more talented than you
and never be afraid of I see people that
are scared to hire people above them
just based on where that puts them and
for me I hire the smartest most talented
people and that I can and I think that's
the best advice and I followed that
advice and what was the second question
best life advice life advice you know I
guess like sounds cliche life is short
and be appreciative and you know that
everyone faces challenges and and and
try to be an optimist and look for the
best in people and that's what I try to
do I mean families is clearly important
to me and that's something I went
instill in my children ah yes over here
so you had mentioned when you started
your foundation that you had visited
Haiti and then to start to focus in the
u.s. at some point do you think your
foundation will begin to focus more
attention on developing economies
I really hope too we recently have we
did an event and Dubai and we also
recently did one in Morocco and San
Paulo so for me it's definitely in the
cards and we want to do that we just
felt that we had to start somewhere
and some places in the u.s. look like
Calcutta and they look like Egypt and
the poverty is it's tough to see so we
thought we could start here and the
thing I love about our foundation most
is that it's empowering women it's not a
charity it's really helping women help
themselves yes hi I was really impressed
when you said earlier that your first
traditional advertising campaign will be
with Estee Lauder can you tell me about
your unique marketing strategy that
might have influenced your me your
meteoric rise well I think we have an
incredible marketing team but our blog
for instance we hired honor Brody she
was at InStyle magazine for 12 years and
we thought it would be really
interesting and this was a while ago so
we started e-commerce nine years ago and
that was unusual at the time
great for another directory consumer but
also a way for us to advertise so honor
came on board to have an online magazine
is how we looked at it create all
original content and it's really about
what inspires us as a brand it's not
Tory Burch centric the company it's
really about other designers with other
artists and musicians is it's anything
that inspires us so between that I
personally do our Twitter and I also do
our Instagram but our team does Facebook
our team does Pinterest our team does
senior Weibo and China so I think social
media is really
our way that we have built the company
until we start to advertise which we
would love to Monday it's been really
the fact that we haven't had a budget to
how involved are you with the
advertising that we're going to see in
September with the Estee Lauder
fragrance launch I'm pretty involved we
have to yeah we've had some we need to
get it there it's not there yet but I'm
excited about the penguin what do you
want it to capture um you know I want it
to be natural and not formal and not and
not so it just more capture a moment of
time yes you mentioned traveling to
China to build partnerships with
producers when you were just getting
started and I was wondering as it was
small startup with one store how you
built those partnerships and then what
you were looking for in those
partnerships it was more about factories
and seeing what they could do and what
we can produce with them I hired a woman
who is amazing and she's still with us
and she had a tremendous amount
experience from Old Navy and then also
Donna Karan so she made the
introductions into those factories and
it was really about learning and also
convincing them to work with us because
really was losing money for them to
produce 50 pieces for one store was not
very interesting for them so we once we
were able to get the numbers up it was
it was a much easier discussion what
kind of numbers were you doing in the
early runs with these new producers you
may now remove units in the front with
one step I would say a hundred two
hundred pieces them not very many um I
want to ask you just to close we have a
few more minutes we have five more
minutes terrific
because supporting women entrepreneurs
is so important to the Center for
entrepreneurial studies here I it has
struck me and you've said this to me in
the past you haven't said it today but
what you wanted to create when you
started the company is
a company that you would want to work
for right I mean that have to do with
and all sorts of studies show that women
in starting businesses tend to do that
they create the companies that they want
to work for and often these are women
who have left big companies and they
want to work in small companies and you
know why guys according to the surveys
the number one reason that they start
companies to make a lot of money so in
talking to women entrepreneurs does this
on you know who want to be you in ten
years does this concern you bother you
or is that okay which part that they
does what bother me
well that women primarily start
companies that they want to work for and
then they don't say that it well I think
it should be a combination of both and
I'll tell you when the first article
that was written on me I have a very
good friend whose name is Jane Rosenthal
and she started the Tribeca Film
Festival and she read the article and
she called me and she said you know it
was a great article but there was
something very disappointing in the
article and she said you shied away from
the word ambition and she said women
have got to start stop doing that and it
made me think yeah and I said you know
you're absolutely right it sort of you
want to be able to be proud to be
ambitious and and also have a company
that you want to work for and I think
that Mika Brzezinski was a mentor one of
our advanced and she often says women
don't know their self-worth
they have to not be scared to ask for
raises and and I and then I started to
relate to that too and I think men as
well it's not just a woman thing I'm not
this giant feminist although I've
definitely believe in women's issues and
I think there should be equal pay and
that's just how it is
so which answer your question I think it
should be both and I think that I don't
know if it bothers me that that's the
only reason men want to our company
that's company
only I said I don't know that's entirely
true but I know you're going to see
sheryl sandberg this afternoon and
cheryl has who i've had conversations on
stage with and conversations private
conversations with a lot and cheryl has
a book coming out in march on this very
subject of women called lean in women
leaning into their careers but Cheryl
says that until we solve the ambition
gap we will not solve the achievement
gap so I well I will leave you with one
more question which is what is power
patty that's a hard one I made a power I
have to think about that power to me is
change and the ability to create change
in the most positive way and if our
company can have an impact and in a
small way that becomes a bigger way to
help create change that would be a great
thing for all of us and all of our
employees Thank You torrei thank you
everyone
you